THE SUPER BOWL IN LOS ANGELES
THIS WEEKEND.
>> Reporter: SOME PROTESTERS
BLOCKING THIS MAJOR CORRIDOR
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND CANADA SAY
THEY'LL RISK THEIR LIVES TO STAY
OUT HERE.
THREE NIGHTS ALREADY, NO SIGN OF
QUITTING.
>> YOU WOULD RISK YOUR LIFE
RATHER THAN LEAVE THIS PROTEST?
>> 100%.
ABSOLUTELY 100%.
>> Reporter: PROTESTS NOW
STARTING TO BITE DEEPLY INTO THE
ECONOMY.
SUPPLY CHAIN BOTTLENECKS, TRUCKS
BACKED UP FOR HOURS ACROSS THIS
BRIDGE AT PORT HURON.
AUTOMAKERS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER STARTING TO SLOW OR
ALTOGETHER SUSPEND PRODUCTION.
WINDSOR'S MAYOR SAYS WHILE
CANADIANS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST, PATIENCE FOR AN ILLEGAL
BLOCKADE IS RUNNING THIN.
>> THERE HAS TO BE A PATH GOING
FORWARD.
IF THAT'S PHYSICALLY REMOVING
THEM, WE'RE PREPARED TO DO THAT.
>> Reporter: THEY WANT ALL
CORONAVIRUS MANDATES AND
RESTRICTIONS LIFTED BEFORE THEY
SAY THEY'LL LEAVE.
>> I'M FIGHTING LIKE OUR
VETERANS DID FOR THE FREEDOM OF
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: PRIME MINISTER
JUSTIN TRUDEAU NOW A TARGET OVER
TOO MANY RULES.
THE PRIME MINISTER SO FAR NOT
BUDGING.
>> INDIVIDUALS ARE TRYING TO
BLOCKADE OUR ECONOMY, OUR
DEMO
DEMOCRACY, AND OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS' DAILY LIVES.
IT HAS TO STOP.
>> Reporter: MICHIGAN'S GOVERNOR
DEMANDING THAT THE BORDER
CROSSING BE REOPENED, CALLING
THE BLOCKADE UNACCEPTABLE.
ANTI-MANDATE ANGER SIMMERING FOR
WEEKS, STARTING WITH OPPOSITION
TO VACCINE MANDATES, EVEN THOUGH
GOVERNMENT STATISTICS SHOW MORE
THAN 80% OF CANADA'S TRUCKERS
ARE VACCINATED.
SOME PROVINCES SUCH AS
SASKATCHEWAN AND QUEBEC HAVE
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED PLANS TO ROLL
BACK COVID RESTRICTIONS.
BUT FOR THOSE WHO BELIEVE THE
GOVERNMENT HAS ROBBED THEM OF
THEIR LIVELIHOODS, THEY SAY IT'S
NOT ENOUGH.
>> YOU WANT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY?
>> NOT ONLY DO I WANT THE
PROVINCIAL ONES, I WANT THE
NATIONAL ONES DONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOMETHING
WHERE THEY CAN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
IF WE CAN GET THE RESTRICTIONS
GONE, THIS LITTLE BIT OF A
DISRUPTION IN OUR DAY TODAY FOR
THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO, WHATEVER
IT TAKES, THEY'LL THANK US FOR
I
IT.
>> Reporter: SO I WANT TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE OF HOW THESE
PROTESTS ARE GOING HERE EVERY
DAY HERE IN WINDSOR.
THE CROWD REALLY GROWS DURING
THE DAY.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE SEVERAL
HUNDRED PEOPLE OUT HERE RIGHT
NOW.
AT NIGHT MOST PEOPLE LEAVE,
OTHERS GO INTO THEIR CARS.
BUT THE RESOURCES ARE COMING IN
BOTH HERE AND WINDSOR AND THE
PRIME MINISTER TODAY SAYING HE
IS SENDING MORE RESOURCES,
POLICE RESOURCES TO OTHER
PROTESTS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
CLEARLY PATIENCE ACROSS CANADA
ARE RUNNING OUT.
JAKE.
>> MIGUEL MARQUEZ, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>>> THESE SUPPLY CHAIN WORRIES
COME AS WE LEARN INFLATION IS
NEAR A 40-YEAR HIGH, CLIMBING
7.5% IN JUST 12 MONTHS.
WE LEARNED TODAY FROM THE BUREAU
OF LABOR STATISTICS.
IT'S THE STEEPEST RISE SINCE
1982.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT INFLATION IS PUTTING STRESS
ON AMERICANS' BUDGETS.
IT'S ALSO A HUGE POLITICAL
LIABILITY FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN.
A NEW CNN POLL SHOWS NEARLY SIX
IN TEN AMERICANS DISAPPROVE OF
HIS TIME AS PRESIDENT.
62% DISAPPROVE OF HIS HANDLING
OF THE ECONOMY WHILE 37%
APPROVE.
VANESSA NOW LOOKS INTO THE
GROWING STICKER SHOCK ON
EVERYTHING FROM CARS TO YOUR
GROCERY BILLS.
>> Reporter: YOU SEE IT AT
CHECKOUT, SEEMINGLY EVERYTHING
IS MORE EXPENSIVE.
THE BENCHMARK FOR PRICES, THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX, UP 0.6% IN
JANUARY AND 7.5% IN THE LAST 12
MONTHS.
THE HIGHEST JUMP IN NEARLY 40
YEARS.
>> THIS IS A CHALLENGE THAT IS
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN OUR
SIGHTS.
WE HAVE WAY MORE WORK TO DO.
>> Reporter: BIG INCREASES IN
CARS, GROCERIES AND ELECTRICITY
YEAR OVER YEAR, AND FOOD UP
NEARLY 1% IN JANUARY.
A HUGE SPIKE FROM DECEMBER.
>> IT'S A CONSTANT REJUGGLING OF
BUDGETS TO TRY TO KEEP UP WITH
THE FOOD PRICES LATELY.
>> Reporter: GAS DID DROP
BY 0.8% LAST MONTH, BUT WITH OIL
PRICES RISING, THAT LIKELY WON'T
LAST.
FILLING UP YOUR CAR COSTS 40%
MORE THAN IT DID A YEAR AGO.
>> I USED TO BUY ABOUT $20 BUT
I'M BUYING ABOUT $35.
>> FOR THE SAME AMOUNT?
>> YES.
FOR THE SAME QUANTITY.
>> Reporter: LAST MONTH, NEW
ALL-TIME PRICE RECORDS.
TRUCKS, SEAFOOD, MEALS AND
FURNITURE SAW THE HIGHEST JUMPS
EVER YEAR OVER YEAR.
AND USED CARS UP A WHOPPING
40.5% IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
THIS BECAUSE OF SUPPLY CHAIN
SHORTAGES, PARTICULARLY THE
ELUSIVE SEMICONDUCTOR COMPUTER
CHIP, WHICH MEANS FEWER NEW CARS
ON THE MARKET.
>> WE'VE SEEN ANYWHERE FROM ZERO
CARS IN OUR LOT, NEW CARS NOW,
ZERO NEW CARS IN OUR LOT TO
HAVING AS MANY AS NINE, TEN, 12.
>> AND NOW TRUCKERS BLOCKING A
KEY TRADING ROUTE BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND CANADA, CUTTING
PRODUCTION AT GENERAL MOTORS AND
FORD PLANTS, WHICH COULD LEAD TO
HIGHER PRICES.
>> WE CAN'T HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE FAMILIES DON'T GET FOOD TO
THEIR TABLE.
>> Reporter: WHILE THE COST OF
SHELTER CLIMBED LESS THAN IT DID
IN DECEMBER, IT'S UP 4.4% SINCE
LAST YEAR.
IT'S THE LARGEST SHARE OF
MONTHLY EXPENSE FOR AMERICANS.
>> WHAT IS UNIQUE IN THE CURRENT
CYCLE IS THAT WE HAVE THIS
EXCEPTIONAL HOUSING SHORTAGE,
NOT ENOUGH HOMES FOR SALE, NOT
ENOUGH APARTMENTS AVAILABLE FOR
LEASING, AND CONSEQUENTLY THE
HOUSING COSTS IS RISING AND
POSSIBLY ACCELERATING FURTHER IN
THE UPCOMING MONTHS.
>> Reporter: INFLATION IS NOT
COOLING DOWN.
THIS IS WHERE THE FEDERAL
RESERVE STEPS IN.
THEIR SINGLE GREATEST TOOL TO
LOWER CONSUMER PRICES IS TO COOL
DEMAND BY RAISING INTEREST
RATES, WHICH THEY SIGNALLED
WOULD START IN MARCH.
>> ON A CAR, IT'S GOING TO BE A
LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT TO COOL
THAT DOWN, ONLY BECAUSE OF LACK
OF SUPPLY AND THE HUGE DEMAND
RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: SOME GOOD ECONOMIC
NEWS, GDP IS UP, UNEMPLOYMENT IS
LOW, AND WAGES ARE RISING.
BUT IT'S NOT KEEPING UP WITH THE
RISING INFLATION THAT WE ARE
SEEING.
MOODY'S ANALYTICS ESTIMATES THAT
U.S. HOUSEHOLDS ARE SPENDING ON
AVERAGE $250 MORE EVERY MONTH.
SO EVERYDAY CONSUMERS, JAKE,
THEY DON'T FEEL THINGS LIKE GDP,
THEY FEEL WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THEIR WALLETS.
THAT'S WHY THESE RISING PRICES
ON EVERYDAY ITEMS IS CAUSING
MANY AMERICANS TO STILL SOUR ON
THE ECONOMY.
>> VANESSA, THANKS SO MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN A CNN GLOBAL
ANALYST AND ASSOCIATE EDITOR AT
"THE FINANCIAL TIMES" AND
RICHARD QUEST, CNN BUSINESS
EDITOR AT LARGE.
RICHARD, FIRST TO YOU.
LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
PRICE SPIKES AT ALL-TIME HIGHS.
FURNITURE, NEW CARS, APPLIANCES,
RESTAURANT MEALS, NOT TO MENTION
STICKER SHOCK ON OTHER ITEMS
LIKE USED CARS, UP 40%.
ELECTRICITY UP 11%.
WE'VE WATCHED THESE PRICES GOING
UP FOR MONTHS.
WHAT SEEMS TO BE DRIVING THIS?
>> TWO FACTORS.
FIRSTLY THE SUPPLY CHAIN THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT.
BASICALLY THE CRUNCH FROM CHINA
TO HERE.
NOT ENOUGH CONTAINERS, NOT
ENOUGH SHIPS, NOT ENOUGH PORTS.
VASTLY INCREASED DEMAND BECAUSE
PEOPLE WORKING FROM HOME.
AND DON'T FORGET THOSE WHO
WEREN'T LAID OFF HAVE GOT
DISPOSABLE INCOME TO SPEND SO
PEOPLE, THE CONSUMER, IS VERY
BUSY.
THAT'S THE OTHER SIDE.
THIS IS ECONOMICS 101.
YOU KNOW THE OLDEST RULE, WHEN
DEMAND CHASES SUPPLY, PRICES GO
UP.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
CONSUMERS WITH MONEY BUYING MORE
STUFF, SUPPLIES CAN'T GET IT TO
YOU.
AND YOU HAVE THIS DEPRESSING
CYCLE, THIS SPIRAL THAT JUST
GOES ON.
I'LL TELL YOU WHY IT'S
PARTICULARLY WORRYING, BECAUSE
EVENTUALLY THIS FEEDS THROUGH TO
WAGES.
PEOPLE NATURALLY, JAKE, WANT
MORE HIGHER WAGES, BECAUSE
THEY'RE PAYING MORE FOR
EVERYTHING.
THE FED COMES IN, PUTS INTEREST
RATES UP, AND ET AL.  IT ALL CO
>> 3M IS THE COMPANY AT THAT
MAKES N-95 FACE MASKS IN
ADDITION TO ADHESIVES AND OFFICE
SUPPLIES.
ACCORDING TO A TRANSCRIPT OF
THEIR EARNINGS CALL, COMPANY
EXECUTIVES APPLAUDED THEIR OWN
COMPANY FOR RAISING PRICES.
THE CFO SAYING THE TEAM HAS DONE
A MARVELOUS JOB IN DRIVING
PRICE.
OBVIOUSLY WHAT RICHARD SAID IS
ACCURATE IN TERMS OF ISSUES, BUT
I'M ALSO WONDERING HOW MUCH
PRICES ARE GOING UP BECAUSE OF
CORPORATE GREED AND COMPANIES
AND CEOs AND CFOs TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS MOMENT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND IT'S A QUESTION
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN ASKING.
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE SEEN IN RECENT
WEEKS THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING
THAT THERE IS TOO MUCH
CONCENTRATION OF POWER IN
VARIOUS INDUSTRIES, THAT
COMPANIES HAVE GOTTEN TOO BIG,
THAT THEY DO HAVE TOO MUCH POWER
OVER THE ECONOMY.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
CONTINUE AS INFLATION CONTINUES
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE YEAR.
BUT YOU KNOW, JAKE, THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER FACTOR THAT'S IMPORTANT
AND THAT'S POLITICS.
THE BLOCKADE THAT YOU'RE SEEING
AT THE CANADIAN BORDER IS
INDICATIVE OF WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE GOING FORWARD.
RICHARD MENTIONED SUPPLY CHAIN
ISSUES WITH CHINA.
SOME OF THOSE ABOUT COVID BUT
SOME ARE ABOUT A FUNDAMENTAL
DECOUPLING HAPPENING IN THE
WORL